yeah I've kind of merged into about what
I was gonna say when we did that video
that full quarantine with the whole full
house cast I took Purell on my hands
I cleaned a dust mop of a mop handle and
then I put the rest on my face like
aftershave let me just say the first
take Candace Cameron Bure said Bob can
you send me another take you spent a
little bit too much time on the mop so I
am both creatures I am I'm a guy who
wants to if there's kids watching I'm
delivering to 9 year olds I I just
recorded Bilborough for my podcast and I
opened it up and said hey if you're
under 1415 don't listen to this you know
or our parents but that'll make him
listen and other people talking to Howie
Mandel and finding out I call him the
prophet of of this whole movement I mean
you can't do this you can't no I know
he's been training for this his whole
life but it's because he has issues and
major issues and real issues and we
talked about them we talked about the
reality of the pain it's not just OCD
it's a deep-seated issue and it's mental
health related and I just did an
Instagram live with him last night
I mean we've gotten so close through
this and we were not together for 30
years we didn't hang out and now it's
like no time went by we can't believe
we're older we feel 15 we fit but he's
he's a beautiful person and I'm I've got
a lot of good guests Tiffany Haddish was
on and and John Mayer and of course
Stamos was my first guest because that's
in the Bible of podcasts muscles and a
lot of good people a lot of funny
wonderful people
I wonder before I want to get to - who
you have on your sort of dream list now
that you are a talk show host because we
all have that list I in the time of
self-isolation I often I've been
thinking a lot about about comics
because I talked to Howie and you know
rock stars can grab a guitar and do
something in their living room and
entertain your fans and it's as
impactful and
else I'm wondering how it feels when
you're a comic because I don't know if
that's something you can do on on
Instagram live where you can do a set
without having an audience without us
being able to hear others laugh what's
your take on doing doing a stand-up set
at home well the great stand-ups a great
standup I'm not auditioning anymore so I
wouldn't put new material I wouldn't do
material if I was 20 and starting out
and was unknown I would probably try to
do material like I was doing it but if
you watch Bill Maher how he does it he's
got them they've got old 50s and 60s
footage of an audience laughing or John
Oliver is doing it in a silent way but
he knows these are professionals friends
of mine that had timing so if I was
doing a show that was on television not
at my own pace but required I would be I
would know how to do it I'd be reading
the teleprompter through the thing and
I'd be adding what I had and you watch
all the late-night host do what they do
during it and some are amazing at it but
you know I'm doing a lot I'm guesting on
a lot of things a lot of different shows
of doing a lot of podcasts that are
visual that are big podcasts so but a
lot of it is just comedy through
conversation and I hosted a benefit one
of the hosts called comedy gives back
and how he was the first host and after
me was Whitney Cummings and then at nas
Webb came on and a lot of friends and it
was really it was interesting because it
was doing and I was doing coded
quarantine jokes not making fun at all
of the issue but saying how are we
surviving during this and the
commonality that we have so that can be
done just like we're doing you know it
was done on zoom or whatever who knew
zoom before this where nobody did I wish
I bought stock well I did too I didn't I
could have bought Red Bull back in the
beginning I'd have a much nicer
background so who is who's on the list
for you who do you want to sit down with
now that you know that this is something
you love and it's something it's working
well a lot of it I've been getting a lot
of the people that I
for tremendously you know Jim Gaffigan
and and Moe mayor's quite brilliant Seth
Green is is on it I Norman Lear I just
did and he's 97 and he's a genius and he
was supposed to do an hour because but
we're dear friends so I get to be
friends with Norman Lear that's crazy
what how did I get lucky and he is
obi-wan Kenobi and people must listen to
him because he knows wherever you can
google and find Norman Lear he is he's
just brilliant and we were supposed to
talk at our we talked 90 minutes and
some things are some of my episodes are
a monologue for me of what I'm going
through or what I'm how I'm observing or
trying to help people through their day
and that's alone and I'm fifty five
minutes or something and then I call
people and that that's a very
interesting thing so and I'm on a three
day a week schedule on Monday Wednesday
Friday on Apple podcast so the dream
list of other people would be most of
the best guests that Joe Rogan has at
Howard Stern s but I'm not looking I'm
looking for people that I have a
commonality with it I love so it's
mostly friends and I know a lot of
people so it's gonna be a long a long
list I have at least one well-known
person a week is kind of how it's going
I wonder if you could take just a minute
right now because you seem to be doing
well through all this I'm doing I'm
doing okay through all okay is your
family great everybody's everybody's
awesome and I just hope that you know
when this is all over we just continue
to check in on people because I think
that's something that's brand new and I
hope it doesn't go away when we go back
to normal but there's a lot of your
there's a lot of your fans that maybe
aren't going through this as well as you
are you know and what do you what do you
say to them what can you say to them you
know it's interesting I got a guy that I
called up named Kyle don't know I called
him up and he was in a real bad way and
he's he's with his mom and they were in
a hotel and they didn't know where they
were gonna go next and he said that I
was the bright spot of his day and
they're just out of money he can't work
and there there hopefully it's
lightening up now that there are places
where he can work as the different steps
open up but he was so appreciative I was
crying and I ended the episode because I
couldn't really function afterward now I
don't like to stop it I don't like to
hit stop I just do the full live live to
recording and it just made me feel so
fortunate but then I worry about my
daughter's I have two daughters in New
York City ones in Brooklyn and ones in
downtown New York and it's bad it's it's
really bad and in LA it's not great you
know there are places where you get
coughed on wrong and you hear about it
but it's real and then there's places it
everywhere where it's under control but
then you find out how they got under
control and you know to be taken away by
the government put isolation we haven't
had that happen so I know yes and North
America has been spared that but my my
heart drops and I that's why I'm doing
this podcast that's why I'm working on a
couple other projects I've been I have a
movie thing that I'm directing right now
where I'm getting people to send videos
and it's online it's on my Instagram and
Twitter and asked quarantine videos and
until May 30th we're taking submissions
not comedy they can be humorous but kind
of what it's been like for you and we're
making a 90-minute documentary out of it
and yeah I mean I'm trying to do my part
which is reach out to people and listen
and listen yeah yeah that's what we need
that's what we need we need we need more
you I I thank you so much this was
incredible I'm gonna miss you no I know
I mean we just started talking where's
the jello shots
I know next when you come up to Toronto
will we'll get it together okay I'm
gonna probably I guess the Queen
Elizabeth is where I'll be playing yeah
and I may be filming there - not that
not the special but I might be shooting
a movie up there so we'll see he's
awesome but that could be a year and a
half from now cuz like then we'll wait
then we'll wait Haitian is the thing
right now man thank you thank you we got
it right now totally appreciate your
time all the best I appreciate yours be
safe sir